in front of me is Radha's love Sikorski
former foreign minister of Poland mr.
Sikorski thank you very much for the
interview
and welcome on the program and I would
like to specially thank you for having
invited us to this really nice country
house somewhere in the middle of Poland
three hours from Warsaw so I would like
to talk about foreign policy and
evidently their current government is
firmly anti Kremlin and most recent and
they repeatedly accuses the former
government of under estimating the
threat coming from Russia and recently
they have got rid of all demos students
and all people who dealt in some way
with the communist regime out of if they
have eventually from them of the
diplomatic service wasn't the right
thing to do well polish Russian
relations are very complicated for good
historical reasons so there's a legacy
there which I think requires a process
of reconciliation and reconciliation
first of all needs telling the truth
establishing the facts and we had that
kind of process with Germany and when I
was in government we were trying to have
that kind of process with Russia as well
the Russian Orthodox Church and the
Polish Catholic Church signed similar
documents that Polish and German Bishop
signed we had a commission for difficult
issues where Russian and Polish
historians were jointly establishing the
facts of common history and we had a
political and diplomatic reset even
before the Obama administration tried
tried that so how did I get you right
that are the accusations which we hear
right now from the current government
are partly valid that the previous
government
underestimated understated the risks
that could come from Russia well no
because I was among those ministers who
warned our partners in the West that
look Georgia is a harbinger of things to
come we told people look what President
Putin said in Bucharest at the nature
summit that Ukraine is an artificial
country that this is dangerous this
means that Russia has not acquiesced
with the loss of empire with the of
earnest of Ukraine and Ukraine's right
to have a separate existence and that
this will have consequences and I can
prove this because thanks to WikiLeaks
the American diplomatic telegrams have
been published so you can find out what
I was telling my American colleagues
could you characterize the current
Polish government as real a Rousseff
orbic yeah when Russian generals
threatened us with nuclear weapons what
are we supposed to feel when Russia
conduct Zapata exercises in which Poland
is the target of a nuclear strike well
that's a very good way of maintaining
the phobia what worries me is that we
don't seem to have any relations now you
know we we talk at each other through
the media or shout at each other through
a keyhole and and that can be dangerous
because it creates room for
misunderstandings but at the same time
remember that the current polish ruling
party ideologically speaking is
indistinguishable from United Russia
it's just that they don't is just the
bear there are nationalists populist who
have radically conflicting interests but
it's a good point that you've just
mentioned yes if you look at populist
parties and the party the ruling party
of Poland join justice is referred to as
a populist or right-wing party if you
look at other parties like this across
the is
in Central Europe you'd see that they
basically like Putin because they share
the same values so they have this they
try to preserve or to restore this
really traditional values they are
nationalistic they euro skeptical
towards the united Europe because there
is a fundamental difference between them
and all the other right-wing populist in
Europe they don't have a border with
Russia we do and they were never
occupied by Russia we have been I think
Russian people should be worried by the
fact that Russia has pretty bad
relationship with the Czech Republic
it's occupied but you don't have a
border and the Czechs didn't feel you
know we are the tank mine so that's
about phobia it's it's about the fact
that Russia is the only conceivable
existential threat to Poland we don't
think it's a current threat but Russia
exercises scenarios and some Russian
politicians say things that are very
dangerous to us so yes many people in
Poland fear Russia saying that if Russia
tries to invade Poland we will our army
our army alone will I will I will say it
in Russian
rascal I seem inlet so main so we are
strong enough yes I think to resist
I think Poland I mean Ukraine proved
quite a difficult target for all Russian
aggression Poland would fight of course
that's what we have we have the 18 the
world's 18th military budget and we
would fight back and I don't think
Russia could win a war with Poland
without mobilization and therefore and
we also part of the strongest military
alliance in the world so you know you
shouldn't try but there are
politicians who threaten us and when
you're threatened you respond regarding
current security policies that are
conducted by the Polish government's so
according to the Minister of Defense he
said it on there in the middle of August
is here he said that he would like to
station they use military base here in
Poland to be sure that just to somehow
deter Russia from possible invasion what
are the pro and co pros and cons of of
this action are you supporting POTUS if
you saw if you are someone in Germany or
even in Russia or in Ukraine five or ten
years ago where the Russia would invade
Crimea people would say now come on
impossible yet it happened you have an
army as an insurance policy for what you
think is not likely to happen but might
happen and therefore you know every
country in the world has contingency
plans for a conflict that you don't want
but but it is possible and just like
Germany during the Cold War had 300,000
Americans on its soil to deter the
Soviet Union so Poland has its own army
and also wants to have worked very hard
to bring it about we want in Poland the
kind of Allied forces that would deter
Russia but not threaten Russia so I
think you know two brigades which is
which is the sort of aim that we have is
the kind of presence that was discussed
between American and Russian militaries
at the time of our accession to NATO and
which I think is reasonable
you cannot invade Russia with two
brigades okay the Verma tried with a
hundred divisions and failed okay so two
brigades doesn't threaten Russia but
reassures Poland do they get you right
that you think that it's it's good to
rely
in terms of security on the United
States because previously you said it
would be better to rely on the European
Union to insurance policies are better
than one
so we should have the American insurance
policy and yes we Donald Trump in the
White House and behaving very strangely
in his press conference with President
Putin that's why we we don't know what
President Trump would do in a crisis
with Russia and that's one of the
reasons one of many reasons why I
believe that the European Union should
also have a defense policy worthy of its
name and I'm very glad that in the new
multi annual budget of the EU there is
for the first time 10 billion euros for
defense capabilities we need them mainly
in the south we need to protect the
southern border of the European Union
from mass migration for example because
I think in the East it's a serious job
for nature but Europe is the largest
economy on earth with its interest
should also have the possibility of
backing up its diplomacy not only with
humanitarian assistance developmental
assistance trade policy but also if need
be with force because I I believe in
Tony Blair's idea that we shouldn't be a
super state but it should be a
superpower if you have the you permanent
use military base in Poland
well we already have permanent pretty
permanent presence of NATO troops in the
Baltic States we have I think two
American bases in Romania Russia
withdrew from the conventional forces
Europe Treaty which limited the presence
of conventional troops on the argument
that we Russia should be able to move
our troops around our territory as we
please well if you can move as you
please
so can NATO so problem wrong but you
some to me is great support of the
current government at least in terms of
their security policies in terms of how
they estimate conceivable as you say as
you put it Fred
is it the wrong impression or your the
current government is talking a lot
about it but is not modernizing the
military as much as I would wish Poland
now spends more than 10 billion dollars
per annum on defense we should be buying
some serious defense system and then
we're not you know that the government
officials officials initiated
effectively a new investigation to the
and to the airplane clearly because they
are not kind of used with the outcomes
of the investigation done by the
national investigative services and by
outside the central national committees
and they have recently they were I think
in Russia to examine once again the
wreckage why they are not convinced are
they not convinced with with their
outcomes this you know I agree
instigation is a joke and this whole
propaganda but this supposedly being a
an assassination is of course a
conspiracy theory that was cynically
used for internal politics just like
President Trump used the birther
conspiracy to to claim that President
Obama was not really American
so these populist movements usually have
some kind of lie at the core of their
ideology and with our populace is that
it's that but Russia but by not
returning the wreckage helped them to
make the case because they were able to
say well they're hiding something
and therefore it wasn't it wasn't an
accident
regarding the domestic satiation
political situation of course almost
three years ago their political party
Alou and justice came into power at
least one year ago
it was still popular it had a solid base
of support among the polls what is the
status quo right now one year head of
the next parliamentary elections here in
Poland
remember that law and justice gained
power in Poland with 38 percent of the
vote
normally this doesn't give you majority
of seats in parliament but the left went
into that election as four different
parties all of them got some percentage
of the world neither cross the threshold
so about 15 percent of the vote was
wasted and that's why we have low
injustice in power and they seem to have
more or less the same what they did
something between 1/3 and 38% of the
world so what's very important is what
the rest of the political spectrum does
if they don't unite
they'll again lose but why are they like
one year ago they were still really
popular inside the country while he
really criticised why Western media and
liberal institutions for stepping away
from democratic principles because every
government gets tired because you make
mistakes because for example they were
caught ministers were called paying
themselves second salaries you know and
this is this was not popular but people
just get tired of their leaders after a
while it is true that in terms of
welfare of social spending the
government is given away more money for
those families which have two more
children that they reversed the previous
government's decision to raise the
retirement age and this was the
foundation for this solid base of
support yes they poland has under this
government introduced a universal child
benefits such as exists in many other
countries you don't get it for the first
child but for all the others and this
has
eradicated poverty in some areas of
Poland at a very high cost this is a
policy in Poland which is very generous
which is costing almost ten billion
dollars per annum and we are doing it at
the height of the of the business cycles
so the the real question is will we be
able to afford it when the economy
doesn't grow quite quite quite as fast
but you know if you mismanaged such
programs then you get a latin-american
outcome parodist kind of outcome you
know where populist say well if you vote
for my opponents they'll take your your
money away and then you can have a cycle
of populism and then you have you know a
country like argentina which was once
very rich of an isabella which was once
a rich now being very poor so one has to
be very careful with with with with this
populism about this issue of migration
as far as I know the previous government
pledged to to a clean 7,000 refugees
when the new government came to power it
took back this pledge that means that
Poland did not take in any refugees
right now is this true it's roughly true
my view is this that if we are to
preserve the Schengen zone which is the
area of free travel without borders
without documents checks without visas
without passports even right for for it
to function the external border of the
zone has to be policed not as countries
but as the Schengen zone as the European
Union roughly so where the nationalists
are lying to you is when they say the
issue of mass migration from North
Africa and the Middle East can be solved
by national means it can only be solved
by national means if you give up on the
Schengen zone if you want a Schengen
zone then you have to find a European
solution that's one issue the other
issue is of
what is our what is our absorption
capacity of refugees you know Poland is
a country that has produced waves of
millions of refugees for the last 300
years
ever since we were we had our country
destroyed by Russia in the 18th century
and I was personally a refugee from
under communism from under martial law
so when the people of Aleppo are bombed
including by Russian bombers I feel that
we need to show human solidarity in a
secure way I feel that you know if we
invite a few Christian if need to be
widows and children that is a safe way
of showing human solidarity with great
suffering and to play this game of
saying that these are these widows are
dangerous people you know in Hungary
very similar political when the wave of
refugees came put up billboards all over
Hungary refugees respect our Hungarian
culture in Hungarian ok so you're
actually mobilized you're mobilizing
your own right-wing nativist
anti-foreigner electorate against your
political opponents and and and these
are cynical get cynical political games
I would like to speak about your past
it's it's it's actually you have a very
interesting personal story because you
start here political career is a
journalist and you went to Afghanistan
which and there was a they Soviet
military presented there and it was in
my estimation a proxy war between the
United States and the Soviet Union on
the Afghan soil you sympathies we're on
the side of magic Eden
I like Russians in Russia
but when Russians come with arms
uninvited to my country or somebody
else's country then I have to resist
that and the Afghans were resisting the
imposition of soviet-type communism on
them just as we were resisting in Poland
so in that sense it was a global war as
you know confrontation between the
Soviet Union and the United States in
that sense at that time there were our
allies did he actually our fight on
their side or you were just a journalist
there as I mentioned already mainly with
the pen and the photo lens mainly but to
some extent well there were situations
you know and you are in at night in the
desert near Kandahar and you're trying
to cross the Kabul Jalalabad the
Kandahar Kabul Highway and there are
Spetsnaz patrols and you hear Russian
helicopters and and you are on a pickup
truck trying to in my case at that time
trying to get from Pakistan to Herat all
the way near the Iranian and Soviet
borders at the same time a journey that
took me six weeks one way at night
imminent threat of over Russian ambush
you know waving your journalistic card
would not help you much in that
situation you know you would need to if
you got attacked you would need at least
to get back to the border so you
actually used a gun occasion so I was
with the unit and I was sharing the
dangers my question is about Syria
because it's also another more or less
proxy war between the United States and
Russia yeah except the United States is
not fighting or it has given up but it
provides some support for the
Rebellion's for the rebels and at the
same time Russia is supporting the Assad
regime on what side is in verse a simple
things and if you had been 20 or 30
years younger what do you have gone to
Syria to fight on the side of the rebels
no because the situation in the greater
Middle East is much more complicated
when the Arab Spring started I I rooted
for the rebels you know for I felt for
the young man who burned himself in
Tunisia and it turned out that when the
a little bit like the Bolsheviks in
Russia taken advantage of by fanatics
and now we have the outcomes that we
have and and I think President Putin
skillfully exploited Western mistakes
namely we thought the choice was between
the Democrats and autocrats he thought
rather more cynically and realistically
that the choice was between autocrats in
mustaches and autocrats with beards and
in Syria he's supporting the autocrat
with well no he might not have a
mustache but his father did I fear that
Russia is going to find out that the
Middle East is much more complicated and
much more dangerous for the country
intervening than the current leadership
imagines the United States has been
making its mistakes in the in the Middle
East
I'm afraid it's Russia's turn now mr.
korsky thank you very much for you